some people favor the ken some people
favor joe
um i don't know i've i just
i enjoy them both now but when i was
younger i went through periods of faith
favoring the joe and then i went through
pairs favoring again
it's it won't get it's what you get from
me at the time you
sort of get these doors open in your
mind that
give you answers and that's important
but
it is just about swinging a can uh
students still today like doing
at the beginning of the year or i
remember one teacher
that was his warm-up for each weapons
class he'd do a thousand cuts
i'd done that once my arms felt like
balloons
for the next 10 20 minutes i couldn't
even
feel my arms so really that was a that
was a wasted practice
cytosensei would say one good cut is
better than a thousand
because you know if you enjoy it
if you feel it if you know what you're
doing
there's a lot to it so
we've gone through the basics you know
how to
bring it out and relax bring out and
relax
you can do this releasing of the hand if
it helps you
obtain where you want to go
the higher the levels like higher the
downgrades
the less you you lean cytoscences
um at his level when he was 19
he would he would cut right up here like
this
and it's about in line nearly with my
solar plexus
and he would say cut to your navel
cut to your center he would shout at us
if we copied him but the point is
his mass was so incredibly powerful he's
cokey you know he hit you with his with
his ken
it was like a a telegraph pole hitting
you you know your elbows would ring
with the power but
we had to do what he told us and i can
understand that now
now at my level sixth down i cut
higher than i teach my students
so teaching you
this is posture
my cuts
there's not a lot of movement in the
upper body you don't see a lot of
sinking
it's because my mass over the many many
years
has built up so that my mass is great
some things we can't teach you i can't
teach you how
i can teach you the the formula
on how to create mass but until it's
poured into your body and becomes you
i'm always i'm just losing me just
losing you if if i'm trying to convince
you that you're going to find it you
won't you'll only find it yourself by
swinging the ken
doing the right things doing the right
actions
in time it will come back
right
so look what look at my body look what i
do
put it into your memory banks think
about
how you if you want to copy it imitate
it
that's how you build your own coke you
you try to get inside
my body and like telepathically work
out what's he feeling what's he thinking
well i'm thinking of nothing to be
honest
i'm just enjoying the swing of the ken
i've spent all those years of thinking
correcting adjusting i just now swing
the can
and when you get to that point
uh you'll know what i mean apogee
thank you
so footwork is really important very
important
and we'll do some close-ups of footwork
and just footwork and not today
but we will spend time because once your
feet
start to float once you can
cut and step and float
so that your your foots are heart hovers
you can start to um
once you start to learn footwork
and you start to learn hypogeary
360 degrees first of all you
do opposites then you do four movements
then you do eight movements and uh
once you become light in hapagiri
the turning whether joe or the ken
it starts to become magical what happens
is first
you have to work out if you're leaning
you know if you're
too much over your body like this
how would you bring your
you know your legs through to turn
easily so first of all it's the suburbs
learn how to be economical
and then you know
once your feet are not heavy anymore
then
it's it's like a jigsaw puzzle we put
the pieces together
and because you'll have these films if
there's something that you want to go
back to you can and that's what i've
done with cytosensei's books and videos
but what the videos and these books
cannot tell you
are the little small points the little
what we call the secrets
what he taught us out of ours
in the parties to one side
these are the important things okay
thank you
for your time don't worry